from the New York Post Costco emergency
food kits spark wild conspiracy theory
by doomsday prepper it's not just a
doomsday prepper there are many and you
don't I think doomsday prepper is is
where they're trying to go you oh that
language is intentional prepper is fine
not everybody who's prepping is prepping
for the Doomsday they're prepping
because sometimes it rains and when
flood waters come in you need food but
let me just start by saying this toilet
paper when Co hits let me just say you
guys have seen the show Who Wants to Be
a Millionaire what a fun show man I
remember back in the Heyday of Who Wants
To Be A Millionaire watching was like
got ABC you know how old was I like 10
years old and they have a Lifeline where
you can ask the audience and it only
really works with like the earlier
questions that are kind of easy you know
it would be like which you know which
country is the first country to do
whatever and then like I don't know I'm
going to ask the audience and then it
shows like most people said a wisdom of
the crowd it's called what we're seeing
with Costco is really interesting
they've released these emergency meals
you can buy and and uh We've we've also
pitched our you know one of our sponsors
safe and ready meals.com now Costco is
selling these these readywise buckets
you can buy that contain is what did
they say 132 pasta meals for
$63.99 these are these are these are
price saving as it were why is Costco
doing this the conspiracy theory is
something bad is about to happen maybe
it's World War III maybe it's Civil War
I think I can up the ante on you it is
not just that there is a deep State plot
like the the the government knows
something's going to happen and they
want people to buy the stuff to be ready
without triggering alarm maybe it could
be worse in a different way
Costco just follows
demand Costco is not being told to do
this so that they can prepare the
population for World War III they're
doing it because the population believes
World War III is about to happen and the
wisdom of the crowd is we need need to
stock up on emergency meals right now
and gold cuz they're selling gold
because it's about to get bad Costco
just simply reacts to the demand yes I
think that's entirely true because the
thing is there are a lot of really good
videos about Costco's business model
they keep fewer items on the shelves
than an average grocery store but the
things that are there they only keep if
they're selling and so they will
occasionally test items you'll see
things that come for a little while and
go but if they think that this is
something people are going to buy it's a
big decision because they only keep a
limited number of items it's interesting
to me that Costco has said people want
this item we're going to keep we're
going to bring it in and we're going to
see how long we can sell it for we so we
did uh we we we I periodically do
pitches for uh one of our sponsors
safeand ready meals.com and when we do
it's only when there's like a big event
that scares people and it's not because
people are scared it's because I
genuinely think people should be
prepared I don't think it makes sense to
this is why I only do it a couple times
per year maybe like five or six it'll be
like there's a major storm or blizzard
happening be like hey guys you should
have emergency food here's an example as
to why you should do it right now it's
pretty wild because I believe Costco has
analytics on on uh on sales and
Distributors I bet they go to one of
their warehouse Distributors and they
pay for data on what's coming and going
so you get a regional Warehouse like
where do donuts come from from your
favorite doughnut shop well small ones
may bake the donuts but the truth is is
there will be like I don't know if
Dunkin Donuts does this but there will
be one big Factory that will produce a
bunch of donuts and then ship them out
to all the stores if you have a regional
Warehouse distributor maybe like Cisco
does these things for restaurants uh
actually a good example is uh
skateboarding I I don't want to speak to
any other industry I can speak I can
speak to how skateboarding works there
will be a warehouse the warehouse gets a
contract with all the big companies that
make Wheels bolts boards and they get uh
distributor prices local skate shops
then sign up to buy from that warehouse
that's how the system works so imagine
Costco goes to that warehouse and says
we will pay you $10,000 for all of your
sales numbers then they see holy crap
emergency food bins are skyrocketing we
carry this we make Bank yeah and
especially since there's someone who's
really particular about what they sell I
think this speaks to uh a change in
American culture right now which is that
people the average person who shops at
Costco is saying I want to be prepared
again it doesn't have to mean Civil War
or anything else it could just mean like
I noticed last year we lost power a
couple times I noticed last year we
couldn't get to the grocery store
because the the snow was too bad on our
Hill like there are all kinds of Reas be
blaming climate change for sure sure
look I I hear what you're saying and and
I understand but I I would take the bet
the average person won't say it but they
think the end is not
I wonder if they want think the end is
night or just generally there is a
distrust in the system around them
there's this movement towards
self-reliance like you get food to be
prepared because you are thinking about
the future and that's a shift away from
our general culture of I want to do
things right now I'm only going to think
about right now that's interesting in
fact this should be an extremely
encouraging change in Costco's policy
because people who think about the
future are people you want around you
people who are you PR preparing for you
know something bad to happen are
concerned about protecting themselves I
will say this maybe it's actually just
for like the past two years I've
basically made the pitch you don't need
the apocalypse to buy emergency food and
I genu believe that's true whenever
whenever we do these pitches I'd say
look like you know there's a hurricane
coming make sure you have emergency food
but the reality is you don't buy it
because you think the world is ending
you buy it because sometimes it rains
and there have been instances where the
power's gone out for several days in New
York when uh Hurricane Sandy hit Lower
East Side was without power for a while
and a lot of SPO had foiled OT SP a lot
of SPO a lot of food has spoiled
oiled uh and uh if if people had
emergency food in their houses they'd
have been totally fine they oh we'll
just crack at the the old stock pile but
the uh the thing about these these these
meals is you don't eat them you don't so
if you have them you only eat them when
you absolutely have no choice so like uh
you go to like one of these um like
fortitude Ranch for instance is like an
emergency I don't call it a bunker it's
more like a outdoorsmanship time share
because in the event the apocalypse
happens sure you can go there but
they're like yeah we have emergency food
but before you ever go into that you are
foraging you are hunting you are you are
finding other ways you are farming and
then when the winter hits and your crop
was bad you crack up in the emergency
food yeah there there are things you buy
for the future and or you buy them
because you don't know when you'll need
them and you don't want to be in a
position where you're without resources
and I think that's again extremely
interesting people who are are saying
everything's fine I I don't need to be
prepared for the future are also saying
I believe that everything that's going
on right now is okay and I think the
majority of people don't feel that way
Mr Jay super chated that Costco has been
selling those in Texas for a long time I
was going to say one of the most
interesting things would be to see a
state byst state breakdown of which ones
are they sh the project reg I imagine
it's probably being sold in Utah as well
cuz the LDS church teaches people to
stockpile significantly in case of you
know storms or anything else that may
happen the point however it's that
people who did not notice these before
are now noticing them so that you know
actually it's quite simple Costco said
hey you know we've been selling these
things in Texas and sales have been
skyrocketing let's start carrying them
in other stores I think we'll make money
capitalism baby yeah and now you can
look at and be like why are people
buying so much of this because you're a
good salesman and we should all be
prepared no it could also be the thing
that for a lot of them like they were
there it's just that now they are
thinking about the end is n so they
noticed the emergency pack more now than
they would have when they were kind of
under the illusion that things were
better than they were before I think
that's a good cultural shift though in
general people should be buying things
like this on a consistent basis I mean
it just in my mind it's like people are
starting to trust the government less
and less which is of course a good thing
there's no negative when it comes to
that you actually don't need to buy
these things on a on a regular basis oh
no I mean I don't I can't speak depend
on the size or how long do if you're
just like buying canned food to prepare
it that's when you do regularly can
canned foods don't even last that long
to be honest but uh the the the
emergency buckets that we've pitched
last 25 years if they're stoed in stored
in a cool cool dry Place 25 years you
buy you buy one you never buy them again
your family grows remember when they uh
when the government released that list
of things that were like signs of
domestic terrorists uh there was like uh
self reliance canning your own Goods
making things like that anything that
involved yeah any type of homesteading
was labeled as farri extremist Behavior
okay I just saw this picture for the
first time oh that is awesome freeze
dried vanilla ice cream
sandwiches what do you do do you like
put it in a bowl of milk no you just
just eat it it at like Aerospace Museum
yeah
free I've had freeze dried ice cream
before and it's like it's it's I don't
know it's like mer yeah it's like
brittle mering like bri part it's
delicious chewy delicious I get one of
these and do a review on the show we can
you rehydrate it I I imagine you could I
don't know I don't see why you couldn't
we have to freeze it again obviously
though yeah once you rehydrated it you
just stick it in the snow yeah what
would happen the freeze would the ice
cream just turn like if you rehydrate
would just turn liquid yeah that's why I
think so and then you'd have to freeze
that again and then you'd have like
reconstituted ice cream which I don't
know why you'd do that I bet if you
dipped it in milk it would be awesome
yeah it probably would be I I have never
done that but I learned that uh full
grown cows make up to like 12 gallons of
milk per day yeah yeah that's crazy dude
there is something hilariously dystopian
about the idea that it's like the end of
the world is coming and the the
businessman is just there like
unbeknownst to anything he's people want
to buy stuff for the end of the world I
guess I'll selling stuff for the end of
the world that's fine
it's uh it goes on I love it and then
the businessman is using the money he
gets to prepare for the end of the
worldly it's perfect the building but
there are companies that were like oh
you're I mean I remember seeing these
videos in like 2012 when people be like
I own a company that will build you a
bunker I have this model it's like
getting a pre sure like I don't think
it's necessarily bad for people to sell
these types of things if you can do it
it's just interesting that it has become
so mainstream Costco was like I think
the average Suburban family might buy
one of these meals family meals man
that's like who is shopping at Costco
you know like it's it's just people who
are regular average Americans who might
look at it and say this this is worth
having again good cultural shift thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at
timcast.net you all next
time